hola
i
cuando edwin hace la invitación a hacer
este evento
y yo dije bueno está bien yo tengo un
montón de cosas de qué voy a decir de
matemáticas en ese un montón de cosas
dije lo primero que voy a hacer es
una investigación acerca de
de los
ay
m
de los escritos escondidos en las
matemáticas y los patrones que podemos
encontrar y encontré y un vídeo después
de eso
muy bueno por cierto se lo recomiendo
buenísimo habla del patrón escondido de
cuatro tercios y después dije bueno no
te voy a hablar acerca de la eternidad
de la importancia de lo que son los
teoremas matemáticos
que los diamantes
son efímeros a comparación de un teorema
matemático siempre va a ser el teorema
matemático muchísimo más fuerte
y ya también había un periodo de eso
muy buenos también
y dije bueno voy a ver qué más podemos
puedo hablar ya sé voy a hablar de lo
que hace un doctor en matemáticas
y ya hay un vídeo
y de lo el sentido que tiene las
matemáticas y que tenemos nosotros el
sentido oculto y hay otro vídeo
y de que la matemática es un lenguaje
y también hay otro vídeo
pero en ese último me quedé pensando
sobre todo yo no encontraba ya el tema
encontrar yo no encontraba ya mi tema yo
no podía desarrollarlo hasta que
llegaron dos alumnos a verme
y me dijeron profesores que yo no sé
estudió matemáticas le doy mucho todas
las noches hasta las tres y media de la
mañana
y saqué cero en el examen
no se sientan identificados por favor no
estoy moldeando a ver a nadie
no estoy volteado a ver a nadie y me
quedé pensando pero es que matemáticas
matemáticas como dice aquí es un
lenguaje
matemáticas es un sentido que nosotros
tenemos pero qué pasa qué pasa porque no
podemos entender matemáticas y entonces
ahí llegó la inspiración y por eso le
puse a esto está esta charla utilizando
las matemáticas
consciente e inconscientemente en el día
a día
pero le agregué a una pregunta más
tenemos un cerebro matemático
todos los dicen que las matemáticas se
inventó desde hace mucho tiempo se
inventó desde antes de la escritura
empezamos a contar
mis alumnos piensan
de un mundo sin matemáticas
se vería así
todo el mundo feliz todo el mundo
contento alzando las manos
cuando en realidad
se vería así
la matemática la matemática ha
evolucionado con la humanidad y la
humanidad ha evolucionado con la
matemática
los matemáticos siempre han discutido si
la matemática se crea o se descubre y yo
lo que digo es que son de las dos la
matemática al principio se descubría
esta es la naturaleza aprendimos a
contar aprendimos a contar con las manos
primero de 2 en 2 de 5 en 5 de 10 en 10
de 12 en 12 utilizamos nuestro cuerpo
para contar y fíjense ese de 2 en 2 es
bien chistoso porque uno dice de dónde
sacan 12
y son las falanges si nosotros contamos
123 las falanges en nuestras manos con
el pulgar nosotros cuando llegamos a la
última falange tenemos 12 y si empezamos
a contar también después con nuestro
otro dedo cuántas veces he llegado a 12
12 24 36 48 60 60 es el número genial de
los babilónicos y de los sumerios y por
eso todavía actualmente seguimos
dividiendo nuestro sistema nuestro ahora
en 60
estos números y ahí y ahí seguimos
usando los
cuerpos para contar si hay muchas
muchas
zonas y muchas este en regiones
indígenas que todavía utilizan el cuerpo
para contar por ejemplo el sistema de
numeración los capi de scapín de nueva
guinea utiliza el sistema 27 este cuando
lo estaba investigando yo no lo conocía
éste lo vi por éste por esta plática lo
encontré en semis o súper genial porque
lo que hace es que a los números que
nosotros llamamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 la que sea
en realidad ellos los los nombres de los
números los relacionan con los nombres
de las partes de su cuerpo
utilizan todavía
el cuerpo para contar
pero pronto fue
rebasado esa potencia esa potencia de
contar con el cuerpo ya no podíamos
contar con el cuerpo y empezamos a
contar con diferentes utensilios el
hueso de django que es uno de los más
famosos
es un hueso es un fémur de
el siervo es un hueso de siervo que
tiene 28 o 29 marcas se creía
originalmente que era porque van
contando los patrones que va
describiendo la luna de la luna nueva a
otra de una luna llena a una arena llena
pero también hay la teoría y esa es una
teoría siente de que en realidad
representa el ciclo menstrual de una
mujer
se crea actualmente que este hueso
y la primera herramienta para contar la
primera herramienta matemática que
existió en la humanidad
la desarrolló una mujer
otras cosas que se utilizaron después
fue la tablilla de arcilla
en los sumerios
con la cual utilizaban un sistema bueno
una numeración con uniforme llegaban a
60 y empezaron
empezaron a contar fue poco a poco
que se fue desarrollando la matemática
pero no quiero hacerla esta una
narrativa de historia de la matemática
lo que quiero dejar en claro aquí es que
todos nosotros
todos nosotros tenemos en nuestros genes
matemáticas
desde básico desde lo más básico que es
cortar pero solo empieza desde contar
tenemos que buscar matemáticas no es
solamente
ecuaciones derivadas integrales y cosas
todas esas feas
es buscar patrones
cuando nosotros buscamos un patrón y lo
podemos entender lo podemos comprender
lo podemos asimilar
lo podemos desarrollar
lo podemos ayudar a nuestra vida lo
podemos ajustar a nuestra vida y cuando
tienes unos patrones que patrones
podemos ver en nuestra vida por ejemplo
un patrón muy clásico poner la alarma
desde que estoy poniendo la alarma yo ya
estoy pensando en matemáticas porque
porque ya estoy haciendo la cuenta de
cuánto tiempo me voy a tardar en hacer
las cosas antes de salir de la casa ya
tengo idea mañana me tengo que levantar
un poco más temprano porque porque tengo
que llevar a los niños a la escuela
porque tengo que pasar al perro porque
tengo que hacer ejercicio porque tengo
que ir al súper no sé tengo que hacer un
montón de cosas me tengo que levantar un
poco más temprano tengo una alarma ya
puse y lo hice inconscientemente
ya hice los cálculos lo hice
conscientemente otra otra cosa
el viaje de la casa a la escuela o al
trabajo
salvo los que hacen home office
pregunta cuál es la distancia que tienen
de su escuela al trabajo de perdón de la
casa al trabajo de la casa a la escuela
yo estoy seguro que muchos de ustedes no
la saben no saben cuál es esa distancia
pero si saben el tiempo que tardan
eso es un patrón yo no puedo medir la
distancia no sé medir la lista bueno la
podemos medir ahorita buscamos google +
vida lo encontramos pero yo sé cuánto
tiempo me voy a tardar pero también sé
otra cosa sé que si salgo cinco minutos
después del tiempo que ya había
programado no llegó cinco minutos
después
puedo llegar hasta 15 minutos después
puede llegar 20 minutos después eso
también ya lo sé es un patrón que yo ya
lo vi ya lo he visto es un patrón
matemático que ya me forma el cerebro
otros patrones que podemos hacer en la
vida la hora de la comida
siempre todos a las 12 vámonos a comer
en mexico es diferente el patrón en
mexico es hasta las 2 de la tarde o a
las 3 de la tarde no saben las
las horas que pasaba katia de de hambre
y cuando teníamos que llegar hasta las 2
de la tarde de comer
pero es un patrón también nuestro
cerebro ya lo está pensando
el conducir cuando estamos conduciendo
cuando estamos conduciendo ya tenemos la
velocidad vista y no nos
lo hacemos casi instantáneo el cambio de
velocidades no tenemos que estar
volteando a si está entre 40 y 60 tengo
que meter cuarta no prácticamente ya lo
estás metiendo directo
necesito subir 20 kilómetros la
velocidad tengo que subir la velocidad
20 kilómetros por hora más para poder
rebasar al otro de forma segura tampoco
lo piensas aunque es lo que se necesita
hacer ya lo sabes lo estás haciendo lo
estás lo estás haciendo intuitivamente
al programar una salida con los amigos
también saber cuánto dinero se va a
gastar uno tienes que estar haciendo
cuentas son cosas matemáticas que
hacemos todos los días bueno lo de
salida con los amigos y hace mucho que
no pero
lo hacemos todos los días y nos damos
cuenta
somos muy buenos para hacer más para
buscar patrones en las cosas somos
geniales para buscar patrones
voy a poner un ejemplo de un patrón
ahora un patrón matemático
primer patrón patrón 1 1
+ 3
+ 5 cuál sería el siguiente
7 si todo el mundo de acuerdo que el
siguiente sería 7 ok 7 muy bien
este tipo de números cuanto suma 13 57
16 porque lo subieron rápido porque está
formando un cuadrado
un cuadrado ustedes habían preguntado
por qué cuando pones 3 al cuadrado
porque le dices 3 al cuadrado y 13 a la
2 nada más
precisamente porque porque el número 9
se vuelve un cuadrado cuando lo escribió
es así
dime entonces que podemos sacar como
patrón de aquí
13 57 cuántos números qué tipo de
números son estos impares cuántos
números hay
cuatro números impares cuál es el
resultado de la suma de los primeros
números de los primeros cuatro números
impares cuatro al
cuadrado dieciséis y por lo tanto
podemos concluir lo siguiente las sumas
de los primeros n números impares es
igual a
n cuadrada
vamos con el segundo patrón segundo
patrón rápido a ver
123 cuál sería el siguiente más 4 muy
bien ahora si nosotros se llamaban
números cuadrados estos como creen que
se van a llamar
triangular es verdad porque será bueno
hasta el triángulo ok vamos a buscar un
patrón en este vamos a buscar un patrón
es éste verá primero lo que voy a hacer
es duplicarlo ya lo tengo doblado yo lo
tengo duplicado ahora lo que voy a hacer
es girar lo gíralo a esta hoja ahora
acerca lo
si más ahí está ya vieron el patrón
se formó que figura se formó
un rectángulo de cuánto es el lado
la altura de 4 y cuánto es la base de
415 o sea 14 por
520 muy bien 4 por 5 20 pero no
queríamos la suma de los círculos que
están en el cuadrado es no queríamos el
rectángulo que queríamos
queríamos el triángulo que tenemos que
hacer no es dividirlo entre dos y
entonces la suma de estos números uno
más 234 es 4 por 5 entre 2 a ver dime
rápido psico así con cuatro números uno
dos tres cuatro es cuatro por cinco
entre dos cuánto es con siete números
sería 7 por 8 entre 27 por 8 entre 2 si
se suman los primeros 10 números
10 por 11 entre dos si queda claro es 10
por el siguiente un número por el
siguiente y por lo tanto el patrón que
encontraríamos aquí sería
la suma de los primeros n serían n por n
1 entre 2 ya vieron como lo vieron todos
si lo vieron no lo vieron ya valió lo
regreso ok
tenía que decirle la plaza verdad ya
valió ok
tenemos un cerebro matemático
sí
pero entonces la pregunta que desató
todo el día de ayer
porque me cuesta tanto las matemáticas
las matemáticas
son una habilidad que se adquiere
trabajando como todas las habilidades si
tú quieres ir a jugar al fútbol puedes
jugar fútbol pero si tú no lo practicas
no vas a mejorar
tienes que trabajarlo no es
se desarrolla con mucho trabajo miren lo
conocen
todo mundo tiene dos piernas pero
alcanzarlo a él
claro
él tuvo una ventaja genética podemos
decirlo la altura tenemos larga data
genética la altura
y
no lo vamos a alcanzar tal vez nunca es
el hombre más rápido del mundo la gente
que practica este deporte también no lo
alcanza por la ventaja genética pero
pero
si no hubiera trabajado nunca esa
ventaja nunca habría alcanzado no los
guns abrió la caja nunca hubiéramos
podido jugar como judit polgár ajedrez
nunca había de hubiera podido dar a
michael jordan jugar básquetbol
elena y el silva lleva para volar
o alguno de estos dos los conocen si si
ellos nunca hubieran tenido un balón de
fútbol y se los hubieran dado por
primera vez a los 20 años
creen que hubieran sido lo que son
entonces lo que les digo es lo siguiente
nunca dejes de creer en ti
me entró cerebro matemático
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah